[音楽]
n ame
ao 株洋一です
第2セッションてのびっくりしちゃったんですよパフォーマンスいっぱいのセッション
で私一人がですね
すごく硬い話をすることになっていますのでよろしくお願いしたいと思います
今日お話したいのはえーっ
好奇心はエンジンっていう話です
なんだ言っていう話でしょうけど何のためのエンジン化
私があのここで影響しゃべりたいのはですね
その自分で自発的にいろんなことを学んでいくという時に好奇心がすごいエンジンに
なりますよということをしゃべりたということでこういう題目にさせていただきました
で一番ですねあの私が今は気にしていることは a
まああの暗記型とかあるいは自動的な学習2がすごく蔓延してきた
特にこういうことを感じ始めたのはですね私あの
7年間くらいあの先生をしていきましたけれど
この東京大学でも先制していきますだけどちょうど20世紀になるちょっと前ぐらい
からですね
あの私の研究室でくる学生さが妙なことを言う
一つはですねその我々ところエレクトロニクスの研究した訳ですけどそこで
電子デバイストランジスターみたいなもんですねそういうものを新しい原因なものを
作ろうとしたんですね
それの
機能をですね計算して出してくださいと言ったらなんか見たいは式のですねつまんない
ことができて何で君この式使ったのって教科書に出ていましたからって言うんですね
我々は新しい原理で全然にあの今までのその半導体中使ったのと違う
デバイスを作ろうとしているのにも関わらず同じ式スコアを使うなど
ということで使ったや私はこれしか習っていません左手ですね
あれ好きをみんな丸ごと暗記してそれを使うのかっていうのにそのとき初めて知った
わけです
それから以降そういうのはどんどん出てきましてへ
エレクトロニクスの分野のにんですねたくさんの学生さんが
金融業界だとかですね証券とか銀行に就職する
どうしてそういうとこ行くのって嫌エレクトロニクスは点数の上でですね来やすかった
からきたんですけどですねちょっとあれ私の印象と違うなっていうことがよく起きるに
なってきたんですね
で
え
まあ私としてはですねそのちょっと自分の経験を踏まえてですね
自分から始まる学びっていうのは何かということを
ここで喋ってみたいと思う
私自身はですねすごくそのくせのある
学生というかな高校時代性とだったんですね
でとまぁ理系の科目は大好きにものすごく勉強しました
他の科目はほとんど勉強しなかったんですね
でそのころですねえとそのエレクトロニクスの分野をトークライブが y という
メールのでそこで受験しようと思ってたんですが
東北大学は非常に厳しい関門があって
全科目がですね最低20%の点数を取らないと合格できない
10%と優しいかも知れ8000けど私にとってはすごくそれが辛かったんですね
そしたら高校の同級生がですねお前あの理系全部取れるかっていうかおり計7満点
取れると思うよって言ったらじゃあ計算してみると残りのね
文化系の科目全体で平均20%れればいいよと言うんですね
平均脳が楽じゃないか
それでええ灯台を受けてですね多分吉里吉里最低の前税とったんじゃないかと思います
当時は入試センター試験とはありませんでしたから
で11件はあったんですがほとんど人試験で投了な人でないで ec 試験を受け
なかったって言うんですね
まあ辛くも東京大学に入ったというのは自分自身がそういうですね好きなことしか勉強
しない
タイプだったっていうんでさっきのようにですね好きでもないけど学科に来た世界です
ねそういうのは非常にビックリしたということがあります
え
この潘恵子はどんどんどんどんそれから強まってきまして
特に親御さんがですねだんだん工学的になってきたんで
だいたい工業完了しなんかわかっているんですねちょっと親からのプレッシャーも
すごく強い
学生さんがですね自分が5分あの例えば会社に就職したいなと思っても親がですね
イヤーのあなたはこんな会社にいちゃいけませんこちらの方が今株が良さそうだが
こっち行ったらどうだってかあっとか選べちゃう
どんどんあの学生さんのですね希望が本来の報復訪れていくということが起き始めたと
いうのが気になっているところでございます
で競泳
言いたいのはしかしもう少しね
自分のそあの自発的な意思に基づいて勉強するようにまた戻ったらどうでしょうかって
いうのが今日お話ししたい趣旨です
まずですね自発的に勉強するっていうのはここにさっきの好奇心もあっていうその表題
が出てくるわけですけど
コーヒー思ったけどだから普通は自発的に勉強できるんですねまず好奇心があってその
好奇心に基づいたことを勉強すればいいよというのは今日言いたいけど相撲最もですね
今みたいに線
たあああ
試験って言うんですか入試件私はあれが最大の眼鏡だと思っていますがあれがあるが
ためにですねどんな科目でも歳ある程度良い点数を取らないといい大学を受ける資格
すら無くなっちゃうんで
私のいうのは完全に100%やるとどこも行けないかもしれませんけど
まあ仮にですねえっと入れたらそっからあとは
どんどん好奇心に則ってですね自発的に勉強してほしいということが言いたいんです
で何がなぜそれがいいかというと自発的っていうことは自分が好きだからやれ
好きだということはですね好きこそ物の上手なれという言葉があるように
どんどんどんどんその
勉強ですね効率的に進むわけですちょっと勉強って言い方をするのはまたこれ曲者でし
てえっと今教育界ではですね
学習って言葉の奉仕として使えますがにんぐですね勉強は昔ながらスター d とか
ですねあるいは
るけーしょんそういうような言葉を使いますけどこのスタディってナム
もともとスタディオっていう言葉からきているようにスクーリングとかですね
そういう言葉が来まし lk トっていうのは物事を学生さんに体で導入するという
ような言葉からきてますでどちらもですね先生側からの立場でそれも push
push の
そういう教育にイメージがどうしても多々撃っちゃうラーニングっては自発的に自分
から勉強するんだっていうのが漂う積んで今教育界ではどんどんラーニング
いう言葉に代わっています
そういうそういうこともあってですねぜひ自主的に勉強してくだ自発的に勉強して
くださいそうすればですねえっどんどん勉強の効率上がります
だけではなくてですね興味あるからいろんな事を調べますねなんでその分野ではすごく
好深い知識が入れるというんで非常にですね自発的
が
主というのは効率が高い
二回までちゃんと制覇できるって言うんでいいというふうに私は思っ
でもこういう話をすると必ずですね反論が出てきます
一つの分野ばっか勉強していていいんでしょうか
一つの分野バッカー学習していていいんでしょうかだんだん線分バカっていうなかなか
こういう言葉
日本語でしかなくて申し訳ないひとつの子鳥だけスペシャライズしたようなそういう
ですね
a ことやってていいんだろうっていうのが当然疑問として出てきます
でもまあこれは私の経験ですけれど好奇心てないでだんだんだんだん動いてきます
一つのことは本当にずっとやれる人は少なくてマーシュみょだってありますね
いろんなことに興味ありますけど興味を持ったそこんとこを徹底的にある高齢を続けて
いくことによってですね
どの分野も効率よく深いところまで達成できん
で例えば
あのアメリカなんかですとセカンドメジャーという言葉でありますけど自分の専門に
代入専門部やするとこの2つの専門分野を持つとですね
間もかなりカバーできるようになるんですねえということでえっあまり恐れずにですね
どんどんどんどんそれ自分の好奇心のもとずあろう
求める方向にですね学習を進めている木ていいただくのが肝要ではないかというふうに
思っています
でまぁこれには多少仕掛けがいいます私はあの細滝にその東大終わってから放送大学に
就職しましたけれどそこでびっくりしたことがありましてまず入試がない
通信制ですからね何人来ても大丈夫だ2とかあるんですけど
有志がありませんなんでえっ学生さんはですネットからいいですね自分で勉強すると
いう
意識を持った学生さんしかまぁこないということ思います
それからその次ですね
えっと授業料がですねその
単位ごとに撮るんですねほぼ入学料入学料ってありますけどこれ本当に回ちっぽけな
値段で1.5科目分ぐらいしか尾根いただかないんですけれど
ですから単位ごとにお金払ってるんで授業に来たからにはちゃんとそれを吸収しない
吸収できるな抗議をしてくれないとけしからんっていうような学生さんも多いですね
お金払ったんだからちゃんとやれよ福井話からスタートする
で非常にモチベーション高いです他の大学の先生にですね
対面授業て行ってもらっていますあの全体の講義の代替いうパーセントぐらいは対面で
通信制もやらなきゃいけないんですがそういうところをお願いすると先生方がびっくり
されるんですね
まず席が前から待ってく
なんちって昔は当たり前だったんですけど今がもうまぁこずほとんど後ろから詰まって
いくんですね
それから質問っていうともうどんどん質問できます this 歌手もものすごく
河童ずと言うんでそれはなぜかというと学生さんが自分の意思でですね自分が勉強し
たいから大学に入ってそれから
えっとそれなりのお金を払って受けに来てるという意識があるから
そんなこういう仕掛けが非常に大事な
彼となっています
生涯学習っていうのも非常に大事でして日本は世界でもまれに見るですね
学生さんの平均年齢のスペーシアの巣小さい
9いいです多分最低だと思います20歳前後っていうのはね
で海外ではだいたい35からですね40くらいの新たに高分散しているわけです
これもですね学生さんの勉強しようというモチベーション上げているんですね
社会に出て必要性があるところ勉強するからやるんだよと
こういうようないろんな仕掛けがいるんじゃないかと思っています
4つ目はですねこれはまあ手前味噌ですけど
こそ大学でインターネットによる教育っていうのを始めました
これはえーっとまあ通信制の講義っていうのは特に放送大学の講義は全部放送データが
してますんで
みんなきっぱなしになっちゃうんですけれど頭とインタラクティブやるとちょっとだけ
教えて
叶うそれに対して簡単な試験とそれから室いようとやってディスカッションをしてって
こう
いうプロセス何度も続けていくということでやります
まああの本当はこれを教室やれればいいと思うんですけれど
通信制ですからオンラインでやってましたけどまぁこういう仕掛けが台座
インターネットはですねまた学生さん一部の若い学生さんにとってはインターネットの
方だったのなんでも発言できるけど次回に対面だとあんまり質問できないんですて学生
さんいますねそのためにも良いだろうというふうに思ってましてこういう仕掛け3必要
じゃないかなというふうに思っています
まあこういう諸々の仕掛けをやっていてですねさらに
先生方に今までは教えるばっかいわゆるその座学ですか
しかしなかった先生方にです何とかして学生さんのモチベーションを上げる努力をする
工夫をですねどんどんとりえてってもらって日本の教育を今改善しないと
これから大変なことになるなというふうに感じているということをお話しをさせて
いただきました
で改めて好奇心にですね則ってどんどん勉強してください
でそれはですね世の中の普通の人はそれは非常に単方向的なのでよくないよっていう
ふうに思っているかもしれませんが実は一つの号機じゃなくて複数の好奇心をもって
ですねそこを勉強することによって非常に広い
主権が得られますよそれをぜひやっていただきたいというふうに思います
もう一つ追加しますと実は日本の女あの
学生さんを採用する側にもちょっと問題がありまして
えっと
一つのことしか勉強しなかった奴はその先ほどのようにですね
一つのことしかわからなこういうふうに思っちゃってですね
なかなかその採用を受け入れないということがあります
先生がにもこれは問題あって先生6ですねあることを例えばドクターの学生なんかに君
これを研究しなさいよと言うとそのことしかやらせないんですね
もっといろんなことに関心を持たせるような教育をして出す側もそうする受け入れ側も
ですねえっ非常に深いあの人ある分野に対して深い知識を持っていてそれが1個では
なくて3個ぐらい
あれば堂々と受けるそういう社会的な素地を作っていくことがこれからの日本を良くし
ていくんじゃないかなという話をさせていただきました
どうもご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]